un bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 8 octobre
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
la fête de la science se poursuit
jusqu'au 12 octobre ce week-end la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
propose un village d'animations
rencontre aussi avec une yvelinoise
distingué par la fondation l'oréal
unesco et puis présentation de
l'opération parole de chercheurs lancé
par la région ile de france samedi et
dimanche but qu'organise j'attende 7e
festival de la bd un rendez-vous préparé
en amont notamment à lézat de la marsa
20 attrape des personnes en situation de
handicap ont pu participer à un atelier
bande dessinée enfin huit élèves
apprentis boulangers étaient en lice
aujourd'hui au lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt leur objectif réaliser le
meilleur croissant au beurre d'isigny
deux candidats ont été sélectionnés pour
représenter l'île de france en finale
nationale suit défend tout à l'heure de
notre dossier de la rédaction consacrée
aux mères dans le département et nous
allons rencontrer à ce soir le plus
jeunes maires d'ile-de-france et les
tiges linois des chiffres en constante
hausse 41 % des lits de réanimation
occupé en ile de france pour faire face
au regain de l'épidémie de kobe 19 et
par souci d'anticipation le plan blanc a
été réactivé ce matin par la région à la
région dans la région par la rs pardon
dans les faits les personnels des
hôpitaux seront davantage mobilisés
pendant la période d'activation aucune
mutation et aucune mobilité report
également des congés et des
programmations aussi d'interface
d'interventions chirurgicales pour les
établissements publics comme privés si
besoin enfin l'appel à la réserve
sanitaire
plus que quelques jours encore pour
fêter la science est dans ce contexte
récemment la fondation l'oréal l'unesco
a récompensé plusieurs chercheuse dans
deux yvelinoise elodie in keynes est
originaire de chevreuse elle est
actuellement doctorante au laboratoire
complexité innovation activités motrices
et sportive de l'université paris saclay
à la bourse vient récompenser son
travail sur la marche des tout-petits
mélanie poquet pour la rencontre un
petit marchard bien volontaire à six
mois il est au coeur d'un projet de
recherche comprendre le fonctionnement
de la marche sur le tout petit le thème
de la thèse d'elodie inc 's originaire
de chevreuse étudiante au siams de
l'université paris saclay elle est
aujourd'hui récompensé du prix jeunes
talents l'oréal unesco
on a fait une étude longitudinale donc
on a suivi des enfants depuis leur
naissance jusqu'à ce qu'ils sachent
marché et quand les enfants sont
capables de marcher on compare
l'activité musculaire qu'ils avaient
dans ces mouvements là avec l'activité
qu'ils ont en marchant pour
essayer de mieux qu enfin de voir s'il
ya un contrôle moteur commun entre ces
différents mouvements et des recherches
possibles grâce à une équipe qui entoure
la jeune doctorante des étudiants et des
chercheurs plus expérimentés comme sa
directrice de thèse caroline teulier qui
travaille sur ce projet depuis une
dizaine d'années elodie a fait sa thèse
sur des enfants simple pour comprendre
le fonctionnement du mouvement chez le
tout petit et la bourse real c'est pour
aller voir comment ça se passe chez des
enfants qui ont des difficultés motrices
et le but du jeu est évidemment à terme
du coup c'est proposer des solutions
pour aider les enfants qui ont des
déficiences motrices la bourse d'un
montant de 15 mille euros permettra
l'équipe d'acheter des électrodes à la
taille de ses petits patients
elodie in keynes présentera sa thèse en
la jeanne yvelinoise espère poursuivre
ses recherches à l'étranger et à
l'occasion de cette fête de la science
nous avons aussi choisi à deux parler
d'une opération parole de chercheuse et
de chercheurs le principe est simple et
des chercheurs vont se rendre dans les
lycées franciliens pour des conférences
originale autour des métiers de la
science est aussi de la recherche
l'opération sera lancée en fin d'année
et elle est proposée par la région
ile-de-france pour en parler faten hidri
est avec moi en visioconférence bonsoir
la soir vous êtes vice présidente de la
région ile de france en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
alors c'est un rendez-vous qui vient
juste après un autre les leçons de la
littérature ou là c'était des écrivains
qui se rendaient dans les établissements
pourquoi proposer ce genre de rendez
vous aux lycéens pour susciter
l'appétence en fait des lycéens pour les
métiers de la recherche qui sont souvent
méconnus et donc nous demandons au sein
des délices et les chercheurs se rendre
au sein des lycées pour tenir des
conférences originale de deux heures le
but c'est d'avoir 100 conférences sur
l'ensemble du territoire francilien
donc là actuellement pour cette rentrée
nous avons déjà 40 lycées qui se sont
tant d'hydra au sein de dunes départ de
du département des yvelines
six lycées sont concernés et donc
l'intérêt c'est vraiment de susciter des
vocations de faire découvrir les métiers
de la recherche
qu'elles soient universitaires ou en
entreprise c'est un secteur qui a besoin
de forces vives ce secteur de la
recherche secteur des sciences
oui tout à fait
d'autant plus avec la réforme des bacs
anciennement bac s
il faut susciter davantage encore plus
les carrières scientifiques pour les
jeunes filles notamment nous avons un
programme tout particulier qui est
destiné pour les jeunes filles c'est des
métiers qui ne sont pas connues et donc
dans toute notre logique de travail de
l'orientation des lycéens
ceci s'inscrit dans cette logique la
faire connaître davantage de métier et
faire en sorte que les sciences et les
métiers de la recherche puisse attirer
davantage
alors on sait que les bacs voilà
généraux tels qu'on les connaissait le
ssl ont disparu est ce que ces
conférences s'adressent uniquement à des
des élèves qui sont passionnés par les
matières scientifiques qui ont des
options scientifique ou pas du tout ça
s'adresse vraiment à tous les lycéens
non ça s'adresse à tous et c'est là
d'ailleurs des thématiques qui seront
présentées par les différents chercheurs
sont très larges
elle concerne à la fois les sciences
humaines et sociales certes également
les sciences dites dures mais vraiment
on est sur un panel de match très très
large pour que chacun puisse y trouver
son compte
alors au programme ce sont des
conférences originale qui vont durer à
peu près deux heures à chaque fois
qu'est ce qu'elles ont d'original c'est
conférences qui sont proposés ont déjà
il ya un aspect particulier car le
chercheur il se présente il présente
lui-même qu'enfin la manière dont tu
l'as eu le déclic pour les sciences donc
c'est pas des des conférences classiques
sur un sujet une thématique avec
vraiment une linéarité puis à une
interaction qui est vous dire également
avec le public est vraiment cesser cette
cet aspect personnel des choses comment
lui-même il est arrivé à ce parcours là
qui est une transmission d'une
expérience personnelle et qui ait une
interaction avec les lycéens alors avec
quelques chercheurs justement qui
sont-ils et ce que la liste est bouclée
ou est-ce que vous êtes encore à la
recherche de chercheurs des lycées qui
ce qu'on était candidat est bouclée et
nous sommes en train de l'actuelle mans
de recruter les chercheurs mais il faut
dire que nous avons des chercheurs très
reconnue en ile-de-france qui sont eux
mêmes volontaires et ont souhaité
participer à cette initiative tout à
fait original donc nous sommes assez
satisfaits de cette volonté des
chercheurs d'y participer
que oui vous lui dites c'est un
plusieurs établissements aussi
universitaire des grandes universités
l'université paris saclay qui attaquent
au t2
de notre chaîne tv 60,18 vous le dit
tout et ils sont faciles à convaincre ce
sont des personnes qui ont aussi envie
de transmettre qui ont une importance à
transmettre leur savoir et leur passion
oui je les chercheurs ont là l'image un
petit peu commune
on les imagine dans leur laboratoire en
train de chercher mais il participe
énormément à la diffusion de la culture
scientifique
vous parliez du padd du plateau de
saclay il ya un endroit exceptionnel au
plateau de saclay qu'est la maison
d'initiation des sciences qu'on appelle
la miss qui accueille souvent des
collégiens de tout ile-de-france et les
chercheurs du plateau de saclay viennent
justement transmettre ce savoir ce qu'on
appelle la diffusion de la culture
scientifique
tous les chercheurs sont vraiment
volontaire pour pouvoir diffuser leur
propre savoir alors sur le calendrier
l'opération devait débuter à l'origine
en fin d'année ce que c'est toujours le
cas est-ce que ça va démarrer dès cette
fin d'année 2020 l'infection c'était le
calendrier qui était choisie on est
toujours sur ce calendrier là après si
les conditions sanitaires nous oblige à
revoir le format nous ferons et si les
choses va se doit se dérouler sous
format numérique à distance yens la
région à distribuer des ordinateurs aux
lycéens et donc ils pourront suivre
suivre de façon distant ciel ces
conférences nous avons également
travaillé sur cette option là puisqu'on
voit pas les lycées sont une compétence
de la région ile de france et des
régions en général une dernière question
ça va se poursuivre aussi sur les
prochaines années ou pour l'instant on a
un regard juste sur sur sept sur sept
saisons sur cette année scolaire plus
tôt on parle d'année scolaire pour les
siens à les lycéens 2020-2021 ou est-ce
que ça va se poursuivre aussi au delà ça
se consumera l'année suivante ça c'est
prévu et puis on a bon espoir que ça
prenne de l'ampleur
et comme pour ce qu'on a fait pour les
cordées de la réussite en double enfin
le nom de cordée on espère pouvoir faire
davantage encore que l'objectif de
senlis et donc si sarah un succès que ça
marche bien ce que nous constatons
actuellement donc sa vocation à perdurer
nous l'espérons merci d'avoir été avec
nous faten hidri
et je rappelle que vous êtes là
vice-présidente vice-président du
conseil régional en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et on parlait de cette
opération parole de chercheuse et de
chercheurs vous l'avez dit qui
concernera six lycées dans les yvelines
et je vous le disais la fête de la
science se déroule jusqu'à lundi
prochain à saint quentin en yvelines
d'ailleurs un village des sciences
ouvrira ce week-end il sera proposé à la
commanderie à elancourt samedi et
dimanche de 14 heures à 18 heures
rencontre avec des scientifiques des
artistes des associations sur les
thématiques de la biodiversité de
l'astronomie ou de la biologie végétale
la fête de la science qui se poursuit et
même au delà à saint quentin en yvelines
avec tout un programme d'animations et
de conférences
retrouvez tout le programme sur les
liens qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
dans le reste de l'actualité ce secteur
en crise conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire le cinéma et en septembre les
salons a tiré deux fois moins de
spectateurs qu'à la même période l'an
passé les perspectives sont inquiétantes
comme le souligne lui beau quand il est
le directeur du ciné 7 à elancourt il a
été interrogé par patrick jacques de
dixmude et mickaël est lui d'ordre
[Musique]
pour le cssa je pense que c'est pareil
que pour les autres salles
malheureusement je rentre on est tous
logés à la même enseigne les petits les
moyens les gros je parle je parle de la
taille des exploitations
c'est très très très difficile nous en
ce qui nous concerne mon été à -68 on
est à -65 donc on va dire que ça
s'améliore un petit peu je rassure tout
le monde il ya un protocole sanitaire
qui est appliqué leurs aînés renouvelée
dans les salles le basket obligatoire
maintenant pendant toute la projection
on peut se dire que cet handicap temps
mais pour l'avoir expérimenté à
plusieurs reprises the pardon ça va
c'est supportable
on peut regarder un film avec un masque
quand le film est bon on oublie le
masque je pense que avec une offre qui
va s'étoffer quand même un petit peu
d'ici à la fin d'année une offre de
films le temps qui va nous aider aussi
puisque on rentre dans l'automne on va
rentrer dans l'hiver et cetera
s'il n'y a pas une catastrophe nouveaux
sanitaires ce qui évidemment personne ne
souhaite
je pense que le public va revenir dans
les salles progressivement il va y avoir
les vacances là aussi de de la toussaint
donc en général assez forte période de
fréquentation elle sera bien sûr
inférieur aux années précédentes on vit
on vit une année de toute façon
tellement spéciale je vous parlais en
début de journal du plan blanc qui a été
réactivé en ile de france pour les
hôpitaux au niveau local les communes
aussi se mobilise pour faire face elle à
la désertification médicale la ville de
plaisir a par exemple mis en place cette
mesure
elle souhaite mettre en place une prime
de 10 mille euros pour faciliter
l'installation de médecins dans la vie
le conseil municipal se prononcera sur
cette décision en séance le 14 octobre
prochain
pour être éligible à cette prime les
médecins doivent notamment s'installer
en libéral et s'engager sur la commune
pour trois ans minimum pour rappel une
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé est
en construction à plaisir ouverture
prévue en 2023 suite et fin à présent de
notre dossier de la rédaction toute
cette semaine nous vous proposions
plusieurs portraits de mère yvelinois
pour ce dernier numéro la direction le
perray-en-yvelines à la rencontre d'un
nouvel édile c'est geoffroy backs de
keating qui a été élu lors des dernières
municipales il est le plus jeune maire
d'île de france une rencontre signé
eléonore sinoquet et mélanie poker mon
objectif principal c'est évidemment de
m'impliquer pour notre territoire
à 25 ans geoffroy bex de keating c'est
déjà bien ce qu'il veut et surtout où il
va depuis juin dernier le jeune homme a
été choisi par les perrotin et les
perrotine pour être leur premier édile
il est surtout devenu le plus jeune
maire d'île de france
il a détrôné l'ancien élu paulette
deschamps qui était à la tête du perray
en yvelines depuis 20 ans pour lui son
jeune âge est un atout quand vous êtes
jeune vous avez envie de vous engager
vous avez envie de participer à
l'intérêt général et je crois qu'on a
une génération en quête de sens qui
cherchent à s'investir qui cherchent à
avoir de la responsabilité sociétale
né à paris mais ayant vécu à rambouillet
toute son enfance c'est tout
naturellement qu'il s'est installé non
loin de là opéré en yvelines
le jeune élu a choisi de rejoindre le
party les républicains il y a trois ans
donc c'est quand même un engagement
récent j'ai pas j'ai pas commencé depuis
tout petit a engagé politiquement
donc ça m'est pas venu tout de suite
cette volonté de m'engager en politique
c'est justement dans ce moment-là début
de carrière où vous dites qu'elle est
quel engagement je veux mettre dans ma
vie où est-ce que où est ce que je veux
m'investir et c'est là que ça s'est un
peu déclaré pour moi et que je me suis
investie début de carrière politique
donc mais également début de carrière
tout court
après un master management et
entrepreneuriat à angers il travaille
dans une start up spécialisée dans
l'intérim mais sa carrière prend
rapidement un autre tournant grâce à son
engagement aux républicains il rencontre
anne cabri mère d'orson ville et
présidente de l' agence des espaces
verts d'île de france
il devient son directeur de cabinet à un
moment il ya des gens qui vous font
confiance et qui se disent que vous en
avez la capacité et je crois qu'il faut
être en capacité de dire de faire
confiance à la jeunesse dans mon travail
à lagence des espaces verts de la région
ile de france
c'est surtout de l'accompagnement
stratégique à la prise de décision
sur global mans la protection de
l'environnement à l'échelle régionale
donc voilà un peu mon quotidien nerfs
vice présidents d'agglomérations et
directeur de cabinet désormais à temps
partiel geoffroy backs de kitching a
déjà beaucoup de cordes à son arc
le jeune élu a donc six ans pour faire
ses preuves c'est au programme ce
week-end le 27e festival de la bande
dessinée se tient à buc samedi et
dimanche mais des rendez-vous en lien
avec les événements ont été organisés en
amont également cette année c'est le cas
avec l'établissement et service d'aidé
par le travail de la marsa 20 à trappes
qui a pu en bénéficier l'objectif
toucher tous les publics avec des
ateliers bd
le reportage de justin braz et un
atelier bande dessinée pour les
résidents de l'esat de trappes en
yvelines un événement en lien avec le
festival bd de buc objectif pour la
27ème édition rendre l'art accessible à
tous
on va toucher beaucoup de public ça peut
être des scolaires ça peut être des
publics empêchés ça peut être en tout
cas réunir toutes les forces locales
autour d'un projet autour d'un outil
redoutable qui est l'outil de la bd
aller 7 de la marsa vingt cinq personnes
en situation de handicap ont participé à
la première séance jeudi dernier c'est
vraiment une vraie découverte et puis
une vraie un vrai challenge pour eux et
puis un travail de groupe
c'est à dire c'est des moments où ils se
découvrent ils découvrent d'autres
d'autres capacités
par rapport à leur handicap par rapport
au fait de pouvoir être ensemble
les ateliers sont animés par la
dessinatrice de bandes dessinées céline
olive
elle intervient dans le cadre du
festival pour accompagner les
travailleurs handicapées
c'est vraiment un retrait très
enrichissant humainement on voit que ça
laisse à leur plaît mais comme c'est un
le dessin c'est universel en comics part
ça tout le monde comprend donc tout le
monde peut le faire aussi
au total l atelier bd composée de dix
séances le but
écrire un scénario et réaliser une
planche un travail complet on leur
demandait d'écrire une histoire delà de
la structure et y en a qui n'ont jamais
dessiné donc il faut ça fait quand même
beaucoup d'un coup
donc en fait on les accompagne tout au
long et en fait on pour que ce soit
cohérent enfin qu'est une petite un
petit lien entre les deux on leur
demande de raconter leur leur journée de
travail ou alors ce qu'ils aient les
bons moments qu'ils ont passés dans
l'établissement les dessins seront
exposés au festival bd de but qu il se
déroulera les 10 et 11 octobre prochain
un festival de la bd qui est donc au
programme ce week-end mais pas que cette
animation rassurez vous dans un instant
ne manquait pas un nouveau numéro du
satuc loisirs pour connaître toutes les
idées de sorties en tout cas une
sélection dans le coin dans les yvelines
et pour en parler c'est diaga tsongo bon
soir au mans sarthe est la présentatrice
du 7-8 loisirs quelle idée allez vous
nous proposer ce soir découvrir le
village des sciences et ses animations
proposées à la commanderie à elancourt
dans le cadre de la fête de la science
ensuite ce week-end c'est la deuxième
édition du festival au fil de l'art une
balade culturelle et touristique à
carrières-sur-seine et puis enfin on
fêtera la fête de la nature à carrières
sous poissy où de nombreuses animations
seront proposées tout au long du week
end
on vous retrouve un peu plus tard à
l'antenne sur tv 78 le 7-8 loisirs c'est
à partir de 18h30 pour refermer ce
journal pour la première fois le lycée
hôtelier de saint quentin en yvelines
qui est située à guyancourt organiser la
sélection régionale du concours du
meilleur croissant voilà le meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny
l objectif c'était de se qualifier pour
la finale nationale eléonore sinoquet et
astrid bergère ont pu assister à la
préparation de ses croissants regarder
her say party vous avez deux heures huit
candidates ou sans formation en
boulangerie pâtisserie et âgés de 16 à
18 ans s'affrontaient ce jeudi au lycée
hôtelier de saint quentin en yvelines
il participait à la sélection régionale
ile de france du concours du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny et chacun
avait sa petite raison pour moi bah déjà
pas d'avoir un aperçu d'un premier
concours parce que c'est le premier que
je fais et puis pour voir mes capacités
un peu aussi vora je me situe dans la
profession se mettre face à ses acquis
et s'améliorer c'est juste pour avoir de
l'expérience prendre du plaisir aussi
tester des concours ça fait toujours une
petite sensation et c'est ça qu'on
recherche en fait de l'entraînement pour
plus progressé c'est d'améliorer ma
technique est d'apprendre plus pour
espérer gagner en expérimentation
créé par l'association des professeurs
de boulangerie et la crémerie d'isigny
cette 15e édition du concours demandé
aux candidats de réaliser 24 croissant
il doit être régulier donc ça c'est un
des principaux critères la régularité du
croissant les qualités gustatives
donc on doit avoir un bon goût de
viennoiseries au beurre ils doivent
également être courbé donc
ça veut dire son repli les extrémités
des viennoiseries
l'objectif pour eux il est de valoriser
leur travail leur savoir faire
puisque c'est vraiment voilà on est dans
un métier artisanal et les deux
apprentis qui ont le mieux valoriser
leur métier sont erwan du lycée hôtelier
d'etiolles et lili noise salomé du lycée
de saint quentin en yvelines
ils représenteront l'île de france lors
de la finale nationale du concours les
17 et 18 novembre prochains en normandie
l'élève yvelinoise qui est en finale
nationale de ce concours du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi très belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]